artists didn't just take pictures
they made pictures and the piece that
you see here
by robert rauschenberg is titled fan and
man
3. many believe that
the polaroid film process itself
valued and encouraged invention and
experimentation
it was like a blank canvas on which
artists made their personal mark
consequently artists manipulated prints
with
inks and dyes and um
pinpricks and cutting and collaging and
all kinds of crazy things one
photographer that i knew
actually told me that he put
his sx70 photographs in a toaster oven
to see what would happen
so i chose robert rauschenberg
rauschenberg as you know it was a noted
painter
and a printmaker he was an abstract
expressionist
and he spent his creative life
experimenting in his art
uh rashenberg first used the polaroid
20x24 camera
in the 1980s and this is a huge camera
it's about five feet tall almost as tall
as i am
weighed about 250 pounds and they
put it in the back of a u-haul and they
drove around the streets of miami
he photographed a sides of walls
derelict buildings things like that that
he would then photograph
and document the positive was hung to
dry
now normally you would stabilize and
preserve the image
by coating the print with polaroid fixer
however rauschenberg would have nothing
to do with that he did not want to fix
the prints yet
he took them back to his home in captiva
island in florida
where he hung all the prints on the
studio walls
still without applying the fixer
this allowed them to oxidize change
color
to continually change with air and light
and rain and even using
water from his garden hose on some of
the photographs
so he watched he waited and when he saw
something
in a particular image that delighted him
then
he would get a big bucket of fixer and a
paintbrush and he would paint that
specific area
of the print if he didn't like the rest
of what was going on
he waited he did not fix it he did not
want at that time to
stop the oxidation from taking place
now over time eventually he painted
fixer on the total surface
of each one of the prints in order to
discontinue
the image disintegration the body of
this work is called bleachers
this print is adhered to aluminum sheet
and there is no glass or plexi covering
the surface of the print
so this in a very perverse way could
continue
the organic development of the image
should anyone
god forbid touch the prince surface
then you'd have fingerprints added to
this beautiful image so i hope this
gives you
a sense of a kind of artistic
interference or disruption that took
place to create
what i think is really a beautiful very
tactile
photograph
you